in 1996 the FBI apprehended a man that
eluded capture for nearly two decades
his homemade letter bombs struck fear
across the United States mostly
targeting airlines and universities
earning him the nickname the Unabomber
all told he killed three people and
injured 23 more he took great care not
to leave a trace of evidence and unlike
other serial murderers he didn't seek
glory and fame for his killings if it
wasn't for his manifesto the publication
that outlined his disdain of technology
in modern society he may never have been
caught after his arrest the world was
shocked that this backwoods living
hermit living without electricity or
running water could be the man
responsible for such sophisticated
killings today we explore this man the
domestic terrorist and lone wolf killer
Ted Kaczynski
[Music]
on May the 22nd 1942 Theodore John
Kuczynski was born in Chicago to
blue-collar second-generation polish
Americans Theodore
tuck and Wanda Kaczynski seven years
later the Kaczynski's had a second son
who was called David little is written
about Ted's early years except for one
incident that may have been the impetus
to the boy's tendency to alienate
himself according to his mother and
brother when Ted was a nine month old
baby he developed a severe case of hives
that required him to be quarantined for
ten days in the hospital afterwards
Wanda reported it took a long time for
her son to return to his normal happy
self worried about his shyness and
social development once acclaimed she
considered putting her young son into
studies for autistic children but
ultimately decided against it
one neighbor remembered him as strictly
a loner when Ted was ten years old the
Kaczynski family moved out of Chicago to
the southwest suburb of Evergreen Park
at the time this was a neighborhood
predominantly made up of Irish people
Italians Czechs and poles Ted's parents
would later say that the move out of
Chicago was so that the boys could enjoy
a better class of friends at Evergreen
Park Ted thrived and seems like a normal
kids to most people except for one
exception his remarkable intellect in
the fifth grade
Ted was labeled genius after he scored
167 on an IQ test his high marks put him
in the same IQ range as theoretical
physicist Stephen Hawking and Albert
Einstein dead skipped sixth grades and
then at the urging of school
administrators his junior year of high
school as well Ted would later claim
that his parents pushed him too hard and
being younger and smaller than his
classmates made it difficult for him to
fit in with his peers still he had made
some friends and he was the ringleader
of an outclassed klieg known as the
briefcase boys at Evergreen Park
Community High School Ted was especially
adept in mathematics and science and
spent hours working out advanced
problems in high school he joins the
Ches biology German and mathematics
clubs
he played trombone in the marching band
explored the music of bark and Vivaldi
and wrote compositions for himself
his younger brother David and their
father to perform at home his physics
teacher Robert riffey described him as
honest ethical and sociable Ted attended
summer school and was able to graduate
at the age of just 15
that year he
one of five National Merit finalists at
his high school one former classmate
said Ted was never really seen as a
person as an individual personality he
was always regarded as a walking brain
so to speak
Ted seemed aware of how others viewed
him he later said by the time I left
high school I was definitely regarded as
a freak by a large segment of the
student body and he felt a gradual
increasing amount of hostility from the
other children in 1958
Ted was accepted into Harvard and as
part of the recommendation letter his
high school counselor Louis Gillen wrote
I believe Ted as one of the greatest
contributions to make to society he is
reflective sensitive and deeply
conscious of his responsibilities to
society
his only drawback is a tendency to be
rather quiet in his original meetings
with people but most adults on our staff
and many people in the community who are
mature finds him easy to talk to and
very challenging intellectually he has a
number of friends among high school
students and seems to influence them to
think more seriously during this period
of his life Ted held immense promise for
his future but he may not have been
ready to leave home one friend remembers
urging Kaczynski's father not to let the
boy go arguing he's too young too
immature and Harvard too impersonal as
an incoming Harvard freshman Kaczynski
was 16 years old the Health Service
doctor who interviewed him as part of
the routine screening process noted good
impression created attractive mature for
age relaxed talks easily fluently and
pleasantly likes people then gets on
well with them being among the youngest
and brightest freshmen Ted was housed at
eight Prescott Street a three-story
Victorian house just outside of Harvard
Yard that year the Dean of freshman
skiddy von Stade junior decided to use
the residence specifically for less
mature boys who needed a more intimate
nurturing environment it was a place
where those boys would not get lost in
the larger impersonal dorms so I've come
to the conclusion that while the deans
plan was well-intentioned
putting all the fragile young men
together had the opposite effect it
isolated them making adjusting to
Harvard even more difficult one student
living at a Prescott later said it was
not unusual to spend all one's time in
one's room and then rush out the door to
library or class after his arrest
Kaczynski's housemate Gerald burns wrote
that he was as normal as I am now it was
just hard on him because he was much
younger than his classmates
despite the adversity he took up
swimming wrestling played trombone and
pickup basketball he also had a few
friends
Kaczynski's sophomore year marked the
beginning of in his words the worst
experience of my life together with 21
undergraduate students Kaczynski was a
participant in an unethical study
conducted by Henry amery the Harvard
professor and psychologist best known
for pioneering personality tests before
Harvard Murray had been a colonel in the
US Army and an agent for the Office of
Strategic Services OSS which later
became known as the CIA according to his
colleagues at OSS Murray was obsessed
with mind control and used LSD among
other drugs to determine how to
brainwash subjects there is no evidence
to suggest Murray used LSD in his
experiments with Kaczynski though the
study was officially named multiform
assessments of personality development
among gifted college men and its purpose
was to measure how the students reacted
under stress subjects were told that
they would be debating personal
philosophies with other students and
writing essays detailing their beliefs
and their aspirations the essays were
then turned over to anonymous attorneys
who conducted vehement sweeping and
personally abusive interrogations the
participants were electrodes to monitor
their physiological responses and these
sessions were also filmed later subjects
expressions of rage during the
interrogations were repeatedly played
back to them some sources have suggested
that Murray study was part of the
federal government's research on
mind-control
known as project MKULTRA author Alton
Shay's questions whether the purposely
brutalizing psychological experiments
contributed to the making of Kaczynski
the Unabomber
however by no means can Kaczynski's
bombing campaign be late at Harvard's
door though his staunch anti
technological views are recognized in
part to Harvard's curriculum in the late
1950s Kaczynski earned a Bachelor of
Arts from Harvard in 1962 finishing with
a 3.1 to GPA in his own words Ted later
recalls his experience overall this
Harvard as a tremendous thing for me he
thrived on the hard work and
self-discipline
became enthusiastic about willpower
Kaczynski enrolled at the University of
Michigan in 1962 at the age of 20 and
spent the next five years of his life in
Ann Arbor he earned his master's degree
in 1964 and his doctoral degree in 1967
Michigan it was not his first choice
school he would have preferred the
University of California at Berkeley or
the University of Chicago he was
accepted to all three but Michigan
offered Kaczynski a teaching position
and a financial aid package the Michigan
dead received two thousand three hundred
and ten dollars annually roughly the
equivalent of about $19,000 today during
his time there he specialized in
geometric function theory and completed
his dissertation boundary functions to
great acclaim his doctoral adviser Allan
shields called it the best I have ever
directed winning the Summoner Byron
Myers prize for Michigan's best
mathematics dissertation of the year
Kaczynski published five journal
articles based on this too while
Michigan and three after despite
Kaczynski's academic success here in
twelve days and five B's over 18 courses
and his students rating him as an
above-average instructor he did not
enjoy Michigan he thought the standards
were wretched and the professor's were
mostly sloppy callous and poorly
organized as he said most instructors
and most students did only what they
have to do there was no interest or
enthusiasm or even any sense of
responsibility about doing a good job
the mathematics department was
enthusiastic about him but many others
didn't seem to notice him underneath the
quiet and studious demeanour no one
suspected his rage was building his
ideology forming and it was at this
point that he apparently made the
decision to start killing Kaczynski
later said I thought I will kill but I
will make at least some effort to avoid
detection so that I can kill again
according to Sally Johnson who conducted
a psychological profile on Kaczynski
during his court proceedings it was
during his fourth year at Michigan that
he began to fantasize about breaking
away from society
she wrote he decided that he would do
whatever he always wanted to do to go to
Canada to take off in the woods with a
rifle and try to live off the country if
it doesn't work and if I can get back to
civilization before I starve then I will
come back here and kill someone I hate
Kozinski also shared with Johnson that
he suffered from nightmares and sexual
repression during this time he began
fantasizing about being female and
reasons of the only way he would ever be
able to touch a woman was simply to
become one Kaczynski went so far as even
to go to the university's health center
to discuss a possible sex change that he
had a sudden change of heart in the
waiting room he shared with Johnson his
feelings of humiliation and of disgust
and then suddenly felt better when he
thought about murdering the psychiatrist
just then there came a major turning
point in his life he later told Johnson
like a phoenix I burst from the ashes of
my despair to a glorious new hope in
late 1967 Kaczynski became the youngest
assistant professor of mathematics in
the history of UC Berkeley he was 25
years old he stayed on for less than two
years teaching undergraduate classes in
geometry and calculus before a sudden
and unexpected resignation
no one knew at the time that Kaczynski
never intended to launch his career at
Berkeley he only wanted to earn enough
money to fulfill his plan of checking
out of the modern world and moving into
the wilderness by the mid to late 1960s
Kaczynski had concluded that mathematics
was too close to the evils of Technology
which he despised in 1971 Kaczynski
wrote an essay and it began it is argued
that continued scientific and technical
progress will inevitably result in the
extinction of individual liberty it was
imperative that this juggernaut be
stopped
Kaczynski went on this could not be done
by simply popularizing a certain
libertarian philosophy unless that
philosophy is accompanied by a program
of concrete action
[Music]
after leaving Berkeley Kaczynski lived
with his parents for two years before
building his remote cabin outside of
Lincoln Montana on lands that he
purchased with his brother's help the
cabin was a simple structure with no
electricity or running water at first he
survived working odd jobs using an old
bicycle to get to and from the town he
told himself survival skills such as
tracking game and edible plants
identification as well as organic
farming he visited the library and read
classic works in their original
languages in 1975 he started to see the
impact of real estate development on the
Montana wilderness and it enraged him he
had considered living peacefully but now
all he wanted was to get back at the
system by acts of revenge and carry out
his earlier fantasies of killing from
1978 in 1995 Kaczynski mailed or
hand-delivered a series of homemade
bombs of increasing sophistication he
took great care not to leave any
fingerprints behind and he purposefully
left misleading clues to confuse the
authorities his first bomb was meant for
Buckley Chryst a professor of materials
engineering at Northwestern University
Crist was suspicious of the package and
called campus police officer Terry maker
opened its and the package exploded
injuring makers left hands a second bomb
in May of 1979 were sent again to
Northwestern this time it was a graduate
student John Harris who suffered minor
cuts and burns when it exploded
Kozinski's next bomb was intended to
blow up a Boeing 727 American Airlines
flight 444 traveling from Chicago to
Washington DC the bomb was placed in the
cargo hold and thankfully a faulty
timing mechanism prevented it from
igniting it did release smoke forcing an
emergency landing and authorities stated
that it would have had enough power to
obliterate the plane had it exploded it
was at this point that the FBI opens the
Unabomber case and led a task force made
up of the Bureau of Alcohol Tobacco
Firearms and Explosives and US Postal
Inspection Service analysis on the bomb
materials proved fruitless Kaczynski's
handmade explosives were made with scrap
materials found almost anywhere four
more bombs caused unsuspecting victims
burns and cuts from 1980 to 1985 the
first serious injury though it occurred
on May the 15th 1985 at Burke
when graduate students and to captain in
the US Air Force John Houser opens the
package he lost four fingers and vision
in one of his eyes this bomb was
followed by two more bombs in 1985 and
then on December the 11th of that year
the blast from a nellen splinter loaded
bomb killed Sacramento computer store
owner hugh scrutton this was the first
of three Unabomber casualties Kaczynski
targeted another computer store owner
Gary Wright in 1987 who suffered nerve
damage when the bomb went off after
nearly a decade the FBI was nowhere
close to catching the Unabomber but then
all of a sudden he stopped sending bombs
for a period of six years from 1987 to
1993 the authorities thought he was gone
they surmised he died by accidental
death or natural causes or maybe he had
a change of heart
Kaczynski's reign of terror it wasn't
over though he mailed four more bombs
from 1993 to 1995 murdering two more
people including Thomas J Massa an
advertising executive and Gilbert Brent
Murry a timber industry lobbyist his two
other bombs are severely wounded and
disfigured david gallant are a computer
science professor at yale university and
charles Epstein a geneticist at the
University of California San Francisco
Kaczynski's bombs were often stamps with
the letters FC and the FBI noted the
theme of nature and trees since he often
included bits of bark and branches and
his explosive packages
[Music]
in 1995 Kaczynski contacted the media
blackmailing the New York Times in
Washington Post
into publishing his thirty five thousand
word essay industrial society and his
future the media dubbed this the
Unabomber manifesto and in exchange for
its release word-for-word he would
desist from terrorism in his manifesto
Kaczynski asserts that the downfall of
the human race can be attributed to the
Industrial Revolution and modern
technological society
he claimed widespread psychological
suffering has taken place because of
technology's destabilizing effect and he
argues people spend too much time
engaged in useless pursuits such as the
consumption of entertainment our society
it tends to regards as a sickness any
mode of thought or behavior that is
inconvenient for the system and this is
plausible because when an individual
can't fit into the system it causes pain
to the individual as well as problems
for the system thus the manipulation of
an individual to adjust him to the
system is seen as a cure for a sickness
and therefore as good Kaczynski saw the
only way of returning to wild nature and
freedom was to destroy progress which he
believed was entirely possible the
manifestos reception was regarded as a
work of genius by some and entirely sane
by others it has been compared to Aldous
Huxley's brave new world and draw draw
wells in 1984 James Q Wilson wrote that
it was a carefully reasoned artfully
written paper if it is the work of a
madman then the writings of many
political philosophers jean-jacques
Rousseau Tom Paine Karl Marx are
scarcely more sane
[Music]
following the publication of the
manifesto David Kaczynski and his wife
Linda noticed chilling familiarities
between his brothers letters and an
earlier essay that Ted wrote for three
weeks they pored over years of
Correspondence looking for telltale
clues before contacting the authorities
once convinced the Unabomber it could be
David's brother they hired an attorney
contacted a criminal profiler to analyze
the letters and contact the FBI at the
time agents were actively following up
on over 2000 tips and a recluse living
in the backwoods of Montana didn't seem
to match their expectations
not until expert linguists analyzed the
letters and the essay and determined
that they were certainly the same man
FBI agents arrested Kaczynski on April
the 3rd 1996 at his cabin where he was
found in an unkempt State a search of
his cabin revealed a cache of bombing
components 40,000 handwritten journal
pages that included bomb-making
experiments descriptions of the
Unabomber crimes and one live bomb ready
for the mailing they also found what
appeared to be the original typed
manuscripts of industrial society and
its future by this point the Unabomber
had been the target of the most
expensive investigation in FBI history a
federal grand jury indicted Kaczynski in
April of 1996 on ten counts of illegally
transporting mailing and using bombs and
three counts of murder
Kozinski's defense had attempted to use
the insanity defense in order to avoid
the death penalty that Kaczynski refused
he tried to fire his attorneys and
attempted suicide by hanging on January
the 9th on the judge's order Kaczynski
underwent a psychological evaluation by
Sally Johnson who gave him a provisional
diagnosis of paranoid schizophrenia
regardless he was determined to be fit
to stand trial and instead pled guilty
on all charges On January the 22nd 1998
in exchange for avoiding the death
penalty at the sentencing Kaczynski
displayed no emotion or remorse for his
heinous crimes the contents of this
cabin was sold at auction and netted two
hundred and thirty two thousand dollars
for Kozinski's victims today Ted
Kaczynski is serving eight consecutive
life sentences in a maximum-security
prison in Florence Colorado where he
spends 23 hours a day in his cell he
maintains an oddly active connection to
many people on the outside through
letters and contacts the media with
regularity
the ladder D collection correspondence
since his arrest with over 400 people is
housed at the University of Michigan's
Special Collections library further his
Montana cabin seized by the US
government is currently on display at
the Museum in Washington DC so I really
hope you enjoyed that bio graphics video
if you did don't forget to subscribe to
this channel for brand new biographies
every Monday and Thursday also I've got
another channel it's called top tens on
that channel as you might have guessed
from the name of it we look at all sorts
of interesting top 10 lists you can
check it out through the link on the
screen now but if you're looking for
something else to watch right now why
not check out a biography from the
archives or indeed a top tens video over
there on the right and as always thank
you for watching